allez comme souvent le mercredi on parle
d'éducation dans votre émission le 7 8
avec votre chronique et du Talk original
et ce soir on va parler apprentissage et
oui tout à fait Mathilde est d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure à
l'approche de l'été c'est un peu la
dernière ligne droite pour les étudiants
de trouver leur alternance mais aussi
pour les entreprises de trouver leur
talent alors justement pour en parler
avec nous Nathalie balutaud bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes directrice
campus Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines chez
edu-service donc et du service c'est un
groupe spécialisé dans l'enseignement
supérieur privé qui rassemble 30 écoles
en France et forme notamment au métier
du management du commerce du digital ou
encore du sport alors ce groupe il est
aussi très axé sur l'apprentissage ma
première question finalement c'est quel
est l'avantage pour une école de faire
partie du groupe et du service bah déjà
ils sont nombreux quelques quelques uns
quelques-uns des avantages tout d'abord
nous toutes nos formations sont
sanctionnées soit par des diplômes ou
des titres certifiés par l'État très
important on a un rayonnement national
avec vous l'avez dit plus de 30 campus
et sur chaque campus plusieurs plusieurs
écoles ce qui permet aux étudiants des
passerelles à la fois sur les écoles et
sur les formations et surtout
un investissement très important sur la
pédagogie de la part du groupe et sur
l'accompagnement de nos apprentis parce
que à la fois il faut qu'il soit
performant en entreprise mais il faut
qu'ils aient les codes et la réussite
d'une formation en apprentissage c'est
l'accompagnement et justement 2022 c'est
une année record avec la barre des 837
000 nouveaux contrats d'apprentissage
qui a été franchi dans les secteurs
publics et privés est-ce que c'est un
engouement que vous constatez aussi chez
du service ah oui oui c'est un
engouement important il faut dire déjà
que alors pour vous donner un petit
repère en 2020 il y avait un peu plus de
500 000 apprentis contrats
d'apprentissage
et l'objectif du gouvernement c'est de
former au moins un million d'apprentis
par an à partir de 2027 nous on le on le
on le ressent on le ressent il faut dire
que l'apprentissage apporte énormément
d'avantages à la fois que ce soit pour
les jeunes ou pour l'entreprise et pour
moi c'est le meilleur tremplin pour pour
l'Insertion professionnelle des Jeunes
justement
l'apprentissage et l'alternance alors
parmi parmi ces avantages on a tout
d'abord une expérience professionnelle
pour le jeûne donc la pratique la
pratique en entreprise qui est très
importante qui leur permet de développer
leurs compétences et d'être plus vite
opérationnel lorsqu'ils vont chercher un
emploi ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième c'est que la formation en
apprentissage c'est une formation
gratuite et rémunérée donc non
négligeable
on a aussi
la possibilité
de poursuivre tout son cursus en
apprentissage
ça c'est c'est important c'est à dire
qu'on peut commencer tout de suite après
le bac parce qu'il nous concerne pour
l'enseignement supérieur et aller
jusqu'au bac + 5 ce qui est notre cas
sur nos différentes nos différentes
enseignes et puis
le jeûne qui fait sa formation en
apprentissage dans une entreprise
très souvent et former aux méthodes de
l'entreprise et à une proposition de
contrat à l'issue de son de son
apprentissage et justement quelles sont
les bénéfices du côté de l'entreprise je
suppose que ça permet de détecter des
talents et de pouvoir les garder
exactement alors les bénéfices de
l'entreprise du côté de l'entreprise
sont nombreux également donc tout
d'abord former un jeûne assez méthodes à
ces techniques à son produit etc et le
rendre immédiatement opérationnel si on
lui propose un CDI par la suite ça c'est
la première chose
la rémunération qui est attractive
des charges qui sont soit très faibles
soit pas du tout de charge ça c'est
important et puis aussi participer à la
formation des jeunes et pour pouvoir
passer le relais et détecter comme vous
le disiez des talents alors je le
rappelle vous êtes la directrice d'un
campus qui réunit trois écoles on a
l'école Pigier qui est spécialisé dans
le management on a l'école maille
digitale School qui est plus spécialisée
dans le digital et le numérique et oui
sport School qui est spécialisé dans le
management du sport ce sont des secteurs
qui recrutent en ce moment ce sont des
secteurs qui recrutent notre j'allais
dire notre ADN c'est de former des
jeunes pour les intégrer sur le marché
du travail donc les formations que nous
proposons sont forcément des formations
qui qui préparent à l'entrée sur le
marché du travail donc on trouve du
travail sur tout ce que nous proposons
comme vous l'avez dit chez Pigier nous
avons
différents alors pas que du management
nous avons également de la comptabilité
du commercial de l'immobilier
d'assistanat de direction etc
nos jeunes que ce soit chez my digital
school chez Pigier ou chez
windsportschool trouve à 85% un emploi
tout de suite immédiatement à la sortie
de leurs études on
aussi beaucoup de contrats
d'apprentissage mais on parle aussi de
contrat de professionnalisation c'est
quoi la différence alors c'est quoi la
différence les deux types de contrats
font partie de ce qu'on appelle
l'alternance le contrat des praticages
c'est une modalité principalement pour
les jeunes faciles pour les jeunes
jusqu'à 30 ans juste en dessous de 30
ans et le contrat d'apprentissage le
contrat de professionnalisation pardon
c'est pour les jeunes au-delà de 30 ans
ceci dit que ce soit en apprentissage ou
en contrat de professionnalisation c'est
le principe de l'alternance et dans sur
notre campus nous avons la foi des
jeunes qui sont en contrat
d'apprentissage donc moins de 30 ans
mais nous avons également des jeunes qui
reviennent faire leurs études qui ont
plus de 30 ans qui sont en contrat de
professionnalisation ou en réinsertion
professionnelle
depuis le covid des jeunes en
reconversion qui cherchent à faire de
l'alternance on a c'est vrai qu'on a à
la fois des jeunes qui sortent
immédiatement de terminale mais nous
avons également des jeunes qui ont fait
une année alors soit une année de césure
soit une année
par exemple en université ou autre et
qui se rendent compte au bout d'un an
que soit c'est trop théorique soit ils
sont trempés d'orientation c'est vrai
qu'on a le droit de se tromper on a
toujours droit de se tromper et qui
reviennent qui reviennent en formation
en apprentissage
l'alternance vous en pensez quoi
Philippe voilà que Stéphane Cornesse on
a beaucoup d'alternants moi j'en ai
beaucoup aussi dans mon dans mon équipe
à la communication au niveau
Île-de-France donc ça c'est le c'est ce
que je vraiment je veux dire aux jeunes
d'enfer parce que c'est vraiment le le
bon ils ont ils ont pris à l'étrier en
fin de compte c'est ça ils sont ils sont
dans l'entreprise et quand on a la
possibilité en plus de les former parce
que c'est bien de reprendre des
alternants reprendre faut toujours les
former et tandis que là ils ont fini hop
on les reprend et ils ont déjà ils sont
ils ont déjà la fibre
ouais ça nous aide beaucoup la charge
pareil ça nous aide beaucoup aujourd'hui
chef d'entreprise et je prends aussi des
alternants dans mon entreprise et pour
moi c'est essentiel justement pour
pouvoir les former pour pouvoir leur
mettre le pied à l'étrier et on voit
aussi ceux qui sont faits pour pour le
métier pour lequel il se destinent et
puis ceux qui finalement un moment
disent ben non ben je préfère arrêter je
veux passer à autre chose donc c'est
aussi un
[Musique]
comment un levier pour eux de tester
aussi un métier un marché sur lequel il
se prédestinait au départ quand
est-ce que c'est la communication mais
la communication ça englobe beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses et il y a la
communication c'est très large au sens
du terme donc il y a beaucoup de donc là
il voit vraiment ce que c'est c'est
vraiment très bien et vous avez des
conseils Nathalie Baluteau pour pour
ceux qui n'ont pas encore trouvé leur
tendance au mois de juin
venir nous voir venir chez Pigier chez
my digital school ou chez win déjà pour
notre expertise dans le domaine de la
formation et de l'apprentissage et puis
aussi parce que nous avons su créer tout
un réseau et nous travaillons
actuellement avec plus de 500
entreprises partenaires qui nous
prennent des jeunes tous les ans donc on
peut dire aujourd'hui qu'on est en
mesure de proposer une entreprise aux
jeunes qui se présenteront donc j'ai
dans nos écoles donc j'ai pigé my
digital School et win merci beaucoup
Nathalie balutaud d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau je le rappelle
vous êtes la directrice de trois écoles
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux Pigier maille
digital School et win sport scho